I welcome the new pledges of support
made by NATO allies including more heavy
weapons and military training
this is critical
Ukraine has a window of opportunity to
tip the balance
and time is of the essence today
ministers also addressed the security of
critical undersea infrastructure
the sabotage of the north stream
pipelines has remind us all of the
vulnerabilities we face
ministers thoughts the NATO military
authorities to provide advice what more
we should do including two better
coordination and cooperation with the
private sector so yes things are
happening but we need to continue we
need to step up even more because there
is a big need out there and to provide
Ukraine with ammunition this is now
becoming a a grinding War of Attrition
and a war attrition is a war of
logistics and uh and uh and therefore
this is so crucial for our ability to
ensure that Ukraine wins is able to
retake territory
it's been nearly one year since Russia's
cruel and unprovoked invasion of Ukraine
and nearly a year since Putin's Reckless
war war of choice
plunged Europe into its worst security
crisis since the end of World War II
and the outcome of this tragic and
unnecessary War
is profoundly important to you Ukrainian
security
European security
into Global Security
Putin just didn't just assault a
peaceful and sovereign
and Democratic U.N member state
he also threatened the hard-ons hardware
one system of rules and rights that has
made Europe stronger
and safer for more than seven decades
but things haven't gone the way that the
Kremlin planned
Putin expected Ukraine to surrender
and he expected the world to submit
history
will record something very different
history will remember the courage of the
Ukrainian people
in history we'll remember the
determination and strength
of the NATO alliance
almost a year after Russia's Imperial
invasion of Ukraine
NATO is more unified and more Resolute
than ever
we are determined to stand with
Ukraine's Brave Defenders
for as long as it takes
and we are also determined to protect
every inch of NATO territory
[Music]